[Music]
hey everyone
spider-man is home the new Captain
America trailer just hit and so far my
reaction has just been slapping on my
keyboard and cursing a lot we're all
talking about Spidey yes but there are
some other moments from the trailer that
are totally overshadowed by underoos
we need me put the checkers the trailer
kicks off fully explaining why Captain
America and Iron Man are going
head-to-head the quick and dirty version
is this the Avengers destroyed a bunch
of cities and other movies the
government wants to regulate superheroes
and these two would disagree sometimes I
want to punch you in your perfect piece
and then everyone picks sides including
some new team members and all of a
sudden I'm standing next to some of the
Avengers and it I turned into like a
little kid ant-man gets tiny and serious
in the movie but not behind the scenes
oh oh my god I couldn't keep a straight
face Apollo Scarlet Witch and vision go
head-to-head proving once again Scarlet
Witch is a total badass crossbones
played by Frank Grillo is going to be
one to watch trust us we get a really
quick glimpse of him punching Chris
Evans and my personal favorite new
character black panther
and just because we need to see him
again spider-man on Team Ironman looking
pretty jacked for a teenager
everyone part of me would have just like
to see the web and then waited until the
movie to see the actual spider-man it's
not a hot take I don't know what did you
guys think of your first glimpse of
Spidey I'm on the Twitter machine you
could say nice things to me use our
hashtag et now and I'll talk to you guys
next time